in recent times a lot of celebrities
have voiced their support for renewable
energy the removal of greenhouse gases
and the idea of going green leonardo
dicaprio is a big example
and since he basically owes his career
to them it makes sense that he wants to
save the ice caps from melting
seriously everyone else has gone green
except vin
diesel and everyone else includes
microsoft founder bill gates and a
company called carbon engineering
but perhaps bill gates and this company
may be the most influential actors in
fighting climate change as we move into
the future
so what technology is carbon engineering
going to introduce that will change the
world
well let's find out in this video but
first welcome back to our channel
if you haven't already make sure you hit
the subscribe button and ring that bell
so you're notified every time we upload
a new video
carbon engineering was founded in
calgary canada by a harvard professor
named david keith
the goal of the company is to develop a
carbon removal technology that removes
carbon dioxide from the air
at a megaton scale and to commercialize
the entire venture carbon engineering
utilizes two technologies to make this
goal a dream
direct air capture or dac and air to
fuels
as you can already imagine air to fuels
is a technology that will generate low
carbon renewable fuels from the air
that's an oversimplification but you get
the point
and this air-to-fuel technology is
impossible without the direct air
capture technology since
you know air direct air capture involves
the capture of carbon dioxide from the
air
this process is carried out in four
steps beginning with a fan that sucks
air into a compartment where it is mixed
with a liquid to trap at least 80
percent of the co2
at the bottom of the compartment the
liquid is then precipitated to give
carbon rich calcium carbonate pellets
these pellets are in turn heated to give
off the standalone carbon dioxide the
final step
involves choosing what to do with the
co2 and there are two choices
of these two choices one will have a
carbon negative effect without any
financial gains
what carbon negative means is that the
amount of co2 in the atmosphere has been
reduced
the second option has a carbon zero
effect with financial value and carbon
zero effect means that no carbon dioxide
has been added to the atmosphere
but neither has any been removed the
first choice is called geological
sequestration and it involves
the use of underground reservoirs to
store the carbon dioxide indefinitely
therefore the atmosphere has less co2 in
it than when the process started
hence a carbon negative effect the
second option makes use of the
air-to-fuel solution to produce
renewable fuels
this is done by using clean energy like
solar photovoltaic technology
to electrolyze water to hydrogen and
oxygen and at the same time provide
electrical power to the fuel synthesis
process
fuel synthesis takes place between the
hydrogen from the electrolysis of water
and carbon dioxide from the direct air
capture
this produces hydrocarbons which can be
used as drop-in compatible fuels for
engines directly or after being refined
these ultra-low carbon fuels will be
burned up to release the co2 gotten from
the atmosphere in the first place only
to be sucked back in by the direct air
capture process
this process repeats itself with
renewable electricity and renewable
resources
now after starting out in 2009 carbon
engineering
invested their time in research and
development and prototyping
finally in 2015 the company moved to
squamish british columbia
to set up its pilot plant in this plant
in 2015
carbon engineering carried out their
first direct air capture and in 2017
they made their first air-to-fuel
synthetic fuel also the company is one
of a kind
seeing as they drove down prices
required for direct air capture all the
way from 600
per ton by other dac companies to as low
as 232 dollars per ton
or even lower at 92 dollars per ton with
funding from bill
gates and oxy low carbon ventures they
are planning to build the world's
largest direct air capture facility
in the permian basin texas this plant is
said to be able to remove
1 million tons of co2 annually thereby
doing the co2 processing work of 14
million trees
at that rate carbon engineering would
need 40 000 plants worldwide to get the
levels we need for global warming to be
below the safe 1.5 degrees
for a perspective of the cost let's take
co2 emissions from 2017 as an example
in 2017 32.5 gigatons of co2 was
released into the atmosphere if carbon
engineering was to get that amount of
pollution out of the sky
at their rate of 92 to 232 dollars per
ton
the calculations suggest that they'd end
up spending three to 7.5
trillion dollars on 2017 alone and
although bill gates is filthy rich he
definitely cannot pull that off
however both constraints do not signal
the end of the project
because although 40 000 plants sounds
like a lot and it surely is
there are several types of plants with
more plants worldwide with an example
being power plants meanwhile if the cost
of dacs can remain as low as
across all operations air to fuel could
then return profits that will cover the
cost for further operations
now some of you may be wondering why
can't they just install these devices on
those chimney-like things of industries
and the answer is well they already do
in fact carbon capture has existed in
some form for some decades this is
because during the refinery
these companies used a more primitive
method to extract carbon dioxide
this carbon dioxide was then used in the
extraction process of crude oil however
the aim of direct air capture and
geological sequestration is to create a
carbon negative effect
attaching the dac technology to factory
chimneys will not stop carbon being
created
and added to the system from burning
these fossil fuels it just maintains it
and adds it to the carbon zero example
we saw above however
dac and sequestrations reduce not just
the co2 being put into the air today
but also the excess amount that remains
in the atmosphere from the past
and that is absolutely necessary to
create a negative
dac seems like an absolutely perfect
technology that everyone should look
forward to
however like every other thing in this
world but ice cream it has its
detractors and these global warming
discussions sometimes get
heated and to be honest critics do raise
some good points
for instance there have been concerns
about geological sequestration
one is that it's not exactly clear what
the effect of the carbon dioxide will be
on the soil and plant life in the area
also there are concerns about what the
effects may be if one of these
reservoirs lets its co2 free through
some
accidental discharge also there have
been concerns that a technology that
uses the help of fossil fuel companies
like oxylocarbon ventures and chevron
cannot possibly be working with a
genuine goal
of healing the earth also a different
school of thought proposes that planting
trees to act as the natural sink they
are
is the better way to go however this
clearly doesn't have to be an either or
situation
there's so much work to be done that all
hands need to be on deck with this one
we need both the plants
and the plants to cover as much ground
or air as we can
as for the fossil fuel company critics
there is every reason not to like those
guys
however as it stands these are our major
sources of energy if we were to shut
them down
the world would definitely descend into
chaos faster than the imminent disaster
of global warming this is why despite
his efforts to use more expensive and
eco-friendly things like aviation
biofuel bill gates still refers to
himself as the imperfect messenger since
other aspects of his life still leave a
carbon footprint
we cannot currently detach them from our
lives but they can take us to the next
stage
and being at the forefront of a new
energy source may be good enough
motivation for them to want to put their
weight behind dac
and air to fuel so if there's a chance
that direct air capture can save the
planet then we must try
our hands at it shortcomings with the
system should not be seen as a reason to
shut down the project
rather it should be something to improve
on and make it the best possible version
that it can be but what do you think
do you agree with the critics that
direct air capture and geological
sequestration
is a waste of time or do you think it's
worth trying out let us know in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video make sure to give it a like and
check out more awesome ones on the
simply tech channel thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time